وصل الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض قبل قليل
توام السيامي السوري احسان وبسام حيث سيتم
علاجهما في مدينه الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه
للحرس الوطني بعد اخلائهما من العاصمه
التركيه انقره عبر الاخلاء الطبي الجوي
هذه العمليه هي السابعه والخمسين التي
تجريها السعوديه ضمن جهودها لفصل التوام
السيامي او التوائم السيامي بقياده المشرف
العام على مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه الدكتور عبد الله
الربيع
او ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه هاني الصفيان
هاني مرحبا بك
الان ننتفي سياره ربما الاسعاف التي تقل
التوام السيامي السوري كلمنا اول شيء عن
طبيعه حاله بسام واحسن
نعم اهلا بك يا خالد واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه اذا فريق العربيه يرافق البعثه
الطبيه في مدينه الملك عبد العزيز
الطبيه بوزاره الحرس الوطني هذه المركبه
الان التابعه لوزاره الحرس الوطني وهي
مركبه اسعافيات تقوم بنقل التوام السيامي
بسام واحسان والذين وصلاه للتو الى مطار
الملك خالد الدولي ويتم مراقبته الان صحيا
من قبل الفريق طبي وكذلك متخصص حتى يتم
وصولهما الى المستشفى وبعد ذلك سوف
سوف تقوم فرق طبيه اخرى
بمسانده هذا الفريق الطبي
وتوجههم ما الى
الغرفه الخاصه بهما عموما والده التوام
السيامي الطبي بسام واحسانه موجوده الان
وبينما الصور تلتقط او الصوره الخاصه التي
تلتقطها الكاميرا العربيه لبسام واحسان
سوف التقي بوالديه بسام واحسان مرحبا بك
اولا في السعوديه ومرحبا بك ايضا في هذه
المركبه الاسعافيه ونحن نتحدث اليك اولا
دعينا نتحدث عن التفاصيل بسام واحسان كيف
عرفت
عن التصاقهما يعني في اي شهر
والفرق الطبيه اللي عالجتك هناك ماذا
اخبرتك
اهلا وسهلا فيكم الله يجزيكم الخير
وبسام واحسن انا ولدت بسام واحسن ومن
عمرهم شهرين اكتشفت انه ملصقين وقالت لي
الدكتوره يعني وان شاء الله له العمليه
والله ما في اكرم منه ومن عند من عند
ولدتهم حولوني على تركيا حولوني على تركيا
والحمد لله رب العالمين اعتنوا فيهن
ودخلوه المشفى وطلعوا ليه هون هون لبين ما
صار عمرهم سته شهور قالوا لي بدهن يعني
رعايه الام رعايه امنا حويناهم بالبيت
وقالوا لي بصير له ان شاء الله عمليه بس
لبين اربع سنين خمس سنين كرمال لبين مشان
احسان مريض يعني احسان هو اللي انا يعاني
من مشاكل صحيه اكثر الحمد لله رب العالمين
ناقصه شويه يعني
صار عمرهم سنتين ونصف الان كيف عرفتي عن
انه والله في فريق طبي سعودي او برنامج
سعودي لفصل التوام السياميه في السعوديه
من اللي يدلك وايش الاجراءات اللي
اتخذتيها هنا
نحن عن طريق صديق يعني عرف وضعنا وشرحنا
له هيك الوضع
للسفاره السعوديه والحمد لله رب العالمين
اعطينا رقم من المشفى وتواصلنا معهم
والحمد لله ما قصروا
والحمد لله رب العالمين ادوا يعني
الاجراءات كانت الاجراءات الحمد لله رب
العالمين نترجى من الله هيك يعني الله قدر
معليش والده بسام واحساني المستشفى انا
بعطيك نبذه عنه وبسيطه هو اجرى 56 عمليه
فصل والحمد لله كانت ناجحه هل انت وش
تعرفين عن هذا البرنامج وايش تعرفين ماذا
اللي سمعتي عنه عن المستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي او البرنامج السعودي
وان شاء الله نحن نترجم من الله كمان الله
بهيك
ويقوموا بخير وسلامه
والحمد لله رب العالمين العمليه عم تنجح
معهن والحمد لله رب العالمين الله يجزيه
الخير اذا
هذه العمليه او هذه الحاله هي رقم 134 في
تاريخ برنامج السعودي
للتوائميه خلال الثلاثه 33 عاما برنامج
السعودي
للتوام السيامية اشرف على اكثر من 133
حاله حول العالم
قام بفصل اكثر من 56 او قام بفصل 56 حاله
من 23 دوله خلال 33 عاما قد تكون هذه
الحاله هي رقم 57 بعد الاجراءات وبعد ايضا
الفحوصات التي سوف يقوم بها الفريق الطبي
وتحديدا البرنامج السعودي الفصل التوام في
مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي بمدينه
الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه بوزاره الحرس
الوطني في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات